avant noël ce gros plan sur les
téléphones portables
avec cette question qui revient
régulièrement peuvent-ils être dangereux
pour la santé
les experts en ont débattu aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale conclusion dans le
doute mieux vaut en limiter
l'utilisation notamment chez les jeunes
qui ne compte pas toujours leurs heures
isabelle sabouraud et alexandre dupont
dans sa classe tous ses copains ou
presque ont un portable alors charles a
réussi à convaincre ses parents pour son
anniversaire
je trouve que douze treize ans et pas
forcément utile mais à 14 ans s'est
séparée indispensable mais c'est bien
pour un adolescent neuf adolescents sur
10 ont un portable à l'âge adulte ils
ont connu une période d'exposition aux
ondes électromagnétiques très supérieur
aux adultes d'aujourd'hui et c'est ce
qui inquiète les experts
une étude suédoise a mises en évidence
une légère augmentation du nombre des
tumeurs du nerf acoustique
après dix années d'exposition c'est la
seule qui montrent un risque réel mais
les données manquent en particulier sur
les jeunes en phase de croissance
les enfants commençant très tôt à
téléphoner ils vont accumuler de
l'exposition beaucoup plus que nous
adultes et donc il risque s'il ya un
risque
ils risqueront effectivement d'avoir une
tumeur visible alors que nous on n'aura
pas vu chez des adultes qui ont commencé
avec 30 40 50 ans un communiqué d'autant
plus que la nouvelle cible est en
maternelle ce téléphone s'adresse aux
enfants de 4 ans si les distributeurs
l'ont retirée des rayons
il est toujours en vente sur internet
cette députée pilote le groupe d'étude
sur les portables elles réclament leur
interdiction de la maternelle au collège
c'est chaud qu on n'a pas besoin d'un
appareil de téléphone à 7h pose un
problème éducatif de toute façon et
compte tenu des doutes qu'on a sur les
éventuels risques liés aux téléphones
ça n'est vraiment pas raisonnable
pourtant il est bien difficile de
conclure un danger réel
le docteur de 16 puis les téléphones
mobiles depuis leur création il a mis en
évidence que cette sensation
d'échauffement que l'on peut ressentir
n'est pas lié aux ondes
mais l application du téléphone lui même
et toutes ses recherches depuis 20 ans
vont dans le même sens les études qu'on
a faites sont plutôt rassurantes puisque
quand on fait des études chez les
volontaires même avait les expositions
répétées des expositions de longue durée
à forte puissance
on ne voit pas de perturbation de la
mémoire pas de perturbation
d'apprentissage pas de perturbation des
temps de réflexes des choses comme ça
pour avoir un risque réel
il faudrait en fait des puissances du
téléphone 20 fois supérieure mais en
attendant le résultat d'études sur les
enfants les experts préconisent l'usagé
du kit mains libres et des conversations
téléphoniques les plus courte possible